so I'm going to talk about some work
that I've been doing in a large
collaboration called Odyssey and I'll
tell you a little bit about Odyssey in
in a few minutes but I'm gonna dive
right in before I do that so I've been
working for the last 15 years or
something in in healthcare in in you
know analytical applications data
science applications in in healthcare
specifically looking at large-scale
electronic health record databases and
claims databases which we now have on a
truly large scale we have we have
medical records on a few hundred million
people for upwards of ten years and it's
an experience an extraordinary resource
that can really help us improve what
goes on in healthcare and right now
evidence-based medicine largely isn't
and that is what we're trying to change
so what's on the screen is an example of
the genre the kind of study I'm going to
talk about I'm gonna zero in on for this
particular talk there there are other
aspects to Odyssey but I want to focus
in on these kinds of studies so this is
published recently it's it's just it's
very typical of the genre real world
comparison of major bleeding risk among
non valvular atrial fibrillation
patients initiated on one of four drugs
okay so it's they're doing a comparison
of four drugs in a particular cohort of
people people newly diagnosed with
atrial fibrillation and they're
interested in the outcome of major
bleeding so they did this study in a
large claims database with about a
hundred million people in it about you
know five to ten years of records for a
hundred million people and they you know
they did a propensity score matching
analysis which is by far and away the
most commonly used method and that
you'll see these days and they drew a
conclusion which was when comparisons
were made bla bla rivaroxaban patients
had a significantly higher risk of major
bleeding compared to a pic Seban
patients so that's one of their
conclusions and they they they give you
come some statistical artifacts in this
particular case it's a confidence
interval okay and that that statistical
artifact is all important okay if it's
narrow you know and north of one then
people take that to mean there's
something really going on that there is
a causal effect in play here this but
it's real and if that interval does not
include one people are inclined
dismissive and applicant if it's very
wide they certainly will we'll treat
treat this evidence with a lot of
caution so that statistic and artifact
better mean what it purports to mean
right it better be the case that 95% of
the time those intervals contain the
truth right and 5% of the time they
don't all right here if you prefer
p-values which I don't you know you want
that type one error rate to be 5% if
you're using 5% is your cutoff okay so
question is that is that the case like
what are the operating characteristics
of these statistical artifacts do they
mean what they purport to mean are these
studies reliable there's about 10 or
maybe even 20 years of sometimes very
careful empirical work trying to answer
that question and I'm gonna show you
just one little snippet but the short
version of a long story is no they're
not terribly reliable type 1 error rates
are somewhere in the 30 to you know 50
percent range
coverage of those 95% intervals is
somewhere in the 50 60 70 percent range
it's not 92% right you know awful little
bit it's there's a serious problem with
with the operating characteristics of
these of these studies just to make this
point in a kind of an anecdotal way
here's a paper that appeared in the
British Medical Journal very fancy
journal about oral bisphosphonates these
are drugs for osteoporosis that are
taken by by millions of people all over
the world and this particular study was
done in a large electronic health record
database in the United Kingdom and
looking at the risk of esophageal just
focus on esophageal cancer esophageal
cancer for people who take these these
drugs and they drew the conclusion that
there's a problem right there was a
statistically significantly increased
risk of esophageal cancer in people who
- who are taking these drugs that study
made it was picked up by the New York
Times was on the front page of the New
York Times and the usage of these drugs
has changed drastically in this country
in the last ten years or so because of
this and a few other studies not not not
just this one and it's an observational
study okay actually one thing I should
have said is most of the evidence that
guides healthcare today comes from
studies like this so randomized you
might think most of it comes from
randomized trials no it doesn't right
there are very few randomized trials
okay and in particular there are very
few comparative randomized trials right
so it's the
evidence space and you can quantify this
is large with if you think it's it's
filled with randomized trials it's not
it's largely empty these are the kinds
of studies that are filling in the
evidence space although badly I would
k-o-k rounded at the same time paper
appeared in JAMA the Journal of the
American Medical Association exact same
issue right or at bisphosphonates
Fosamax is a drug you might have heard
of this phosphonates and esophageal
cancer this one drew the conclusion that
there is no association between
bisphosphonates and esophageal cancer so
two studies okay
well meaning there's no obvious conflict
of interest here nothing's anything
nefarious going on just two well-meaning
and highly experienced groups and
analysts addressing the exact same
question and here's the kicker
using the same database right they both
used the UK GP Rd and arriving at
opposite conclusions you might think to
yourself well I you know I spent months
trying to find this example mm-hmm and
you take basically any study major study
observational study in the medical
literature and with high probability you
will be able to find another study and
arriving at a different conclusion so
there are many reasons for this I really
don't believe much of it is nefarious
it's it's there are other reasons one of
them is the process by which we do these
studies it's kind of like arts and
crafts it's well we adjust for this and
we won't adjust for that and we'll
exclude this and we'll do this and that
and all these kind of little decisions
there are dozens of analytic choices
that add that that epidemiologists and
statisticians and so on make when
they're conducting one of these studies
and there is absolutely no way to know
if they're right or wrong right and a
really no way because even even with the
say the best affluence we'll never
really know if those drugs cause the
softer your cancer because no one's ever
gonna do a randomized trial because it's
too expensive and even then you might
not get the right answer but that's
another day's work and so there's a huge
amount of hubris in in the design and
conduct of these of these studies and
that what's what's on that slide there
is an actual quote right I'm a good
analyst my study is right and the other
day all the others are idiots mine is
the only one that's right and that
that's kind of the level of discourse in
in this space so it's not good over and
above that there are a whole host of
issues that that I everyone the room is
probably familiar with at least some of
these if not all of these there are a
whole host of issues that bedevil
observation
studies right non-experimental studies
selection bias who's included in the
study measurement error is all over the
place here model ms specification
multiple modeling P hacking etc etc and
and then the kind of the mother of all
problems on measure confounding that
you're comparing people who took
bisphosphonates with people who didn't
our paper people who took a pic Seban
and people took warfarin well they may
differ in ways other than those drugs
the people who get war for not the same
as the people who get a new fangled
blood thinner okay so you wore it your
own measure confounding is on measured
right so you certainly worry about that
and so there's a lot of you know
challenges that that there are apparent
here that step one basically of any one
of these papers is let's assume that
none of these problems exist more or
less our or let's assume that I've done
such a clever analysis that we don't
have to worry about these things and I
love this quote from from Paul Rosenbaum
you know who are you that you could not
be mistaken and so to segue to usually I
spend about I spend about an hour
beating up and these studies that I did
it in eight minutes
and but but i but i tried to persuade
you is that that there's a there's not a
little problem there's a substantial
problem a public health problem with the
way we as a society conduct these kinds
of studies the way we are generating the
evidence-based therefore the practice of
health care so what Odyssey is about
Odyssey is a worldwide collaboration
involving we've had over 2,000 people
involved in various other sea activities
as active participants and while we're
trying to do is come up with a better
way okay and I want to I want to tell
you a little bit about one particular
large projects that we're engaged in
which and I'm not sure if it's a better
way but you know we're working on it
we're trying to improve it is certainly
we're trying to at least change the way
people think about these studies and do
these studies so there are a few kind of
core principles guiding what we're doing
and the first one is that whatever we do
has to be reproducible we're gonna try
and generate evidence okay from these
databases about the effects of
healthcare interventions and it has to
be reproducible none of the studies I
showed you are reproducible like none I
challenge you to find a single
observational study in the healthcare
literature that you can reproduce but
it's it's it's a huge problem and we
wanted to be systematized now
this arts-and-crafts twiddling knobs to
get you know to because you feel like
it's because it's Tuesday morning and
therefore you gonna adjust for this and
not for that or whatever
none of that an open-source approach to
all of this is available as our code and
and we want to do this at scale so
rather than doing one analysis in one
database what we aim to do is do all
analysis in all databases and we're not
there yet but we're getting there I'll
show you
so rot no pee hacking no cherry-picking
no publication bias do all the studies
so we can see them all okay and at scale
at very large scale the centerpiece the
methodological centerpiece of what we're
doing and relies on what we call others
call negative controls and positive
controls some of you may know these as
falsification hypothesis so the basic
idea of I'll just focus on negative
controls is we identify in a given
situation you're studying
bisphosphonates and esophageal cancer in
that situation and you try and identify
outcomes that you know are not caused by
bisphosphonates okay and therein lies
there's a circularity or how would you
know that if you didn't know how to do
causal inference properly in the first
place let me just slide by that at the
moment we have a we have a very
elaborate process an automated process
for identifying negative controls and
the basic idea is well gee if you have a
set of negative controls then you can
get an empirical null distribution you
don't need to you don't need to rely on
what the textbook says you don't need to
say step one let's assume we have an
unbiased estimator and we know we don't
right so we just run the negative
controls through whatever analysis
you're doing that gives you an empirical
null distribution and then you can get
at an empirical or we call a calibrated
p-value we have shown over and over in
many different circumstances I'm going
to show you one briefly here and the the
calibrated p-values have exact more or
less exactly the right type one error
rate so we essentially adjust the
statistical artifacts so that they have
the nominal properties they mean what
they purport to mean which is why I use
honest in the title they're honest right
and we have we have a similar process
for calibrating confidence intervals we
also have a Bayesian version of this and
so we we adjust the confidence intervals
so that they have 95% coverage okay
using negative controls and positive
controls and we're going to look at the
detail
and yes and so let me just take a step
back for a second and tell you about
Odyssey so Odyssey is there's a
coordinating Center at Columbia
University but it is truly a worldwide
endeavor and it's there are many many
working groups within Odyssey many of
these working groups have now split into
eastern hemisphere and western
hemisphere versions of them looking at
all and any aspect of generating
evidence from large-scale healthcare
data it's an open community anyone can
can can join this there's a very large
scale or repository of our code and that
that runs against what's called the Oh
map common data model so there's there's
a piece of this collaboration which is
which is transformative it's a total
game changer which is we developed we
people developed some early on in
Odyssey and a predecessor project called
OMAP we developed a common data model
okay for these healthcare databases if
you're going to do this kind of research
on these kinds of analysis on a global
scale you can't be writing code for
every last database right so we built a
common data model it's now in version 6
it's there's a lot of people I'm not one
of them but a lot of people engaged in
this effort so there are databases all
over the world are about 80 databases
healthcare databases large scale around
the world that have been mapped to the
OMAP common data model and the pins on
the map there are where there are
Odyssey researchers and there are
Odyssey databases in on every continent
except Africa
which is what working on it and so
they're mapped to accommodate a model
which means you write a piece of code
you test a piece of code say in your
local shop you then send it out and
there's a mechanism to do this onto the
Odyssey Network and people wrote note
there's no centralization of data but
they run the code on locally in their
shop against the common data model and
then we coordinate the results and this
this enables us to do the kind of
research I'm about to describe which is
an honor on an unprecedented scale
Oh HDS i.org I encourage you to get
involved okay so let me let me do a
slightly deep dive three or four minutes
into the this idea of negative controls
so we did a large-scale study on
depression treatments and in the context
of depression treatments we identified
drug farmers no not just drug treatments
actually treatments for depression
and we identified about fifty negative
controls of 50 outcomes that we believe
are not caused so the true relative risk
is one they're not caused by any of the
mainstream depression treatments okay so
what I'm showing you here is I'm gonna
show you a few pictures like this on the
horizontal axis is a negative control
right is a study if you will okay and
the horizontal axis is the point
estimate so one is that is the null
value one has it raised your a relative
risk scale or whatever the vertical axis
is the standard error right so you get
to be statistically significant if
you're under those dashed lines if you
have a big point estimate and and or a
small standard error you get to be
statistically significant and if you're
above it you're not statistically
significant okay so what you see here
this this particular analysis is a
unadjusted comparison of two drugs with
respect to a particular outcome I think
it's MI and what you see here is what
should be 5% okay and sorry can go back
to what should be 5% okay using a crude
unadjusted estimate which is a very
problematic way to do a study and you
might think nobody would do it in fact
it was one in the New England Journal of
Medicine very recently and the type 1
error right here is 68% okay and this is
not P hacking this is just inability to
control for selection bias non measure
confounding and all those issues and you
do with if you do an adjusted method
this is a high-dimensional propensity
score adjustment and it does much better
in this particular context so the type 1
error rate now if you do a fancier
method is 16 percent right but 16
percent is pretty far away from 5
percent right it's nowhere near what it
what it should be nominally the basic
idea of the p-value calibration is we
adjust in a purely empirical way we
adjust the boundaries for our
statistical significance and you can see
there it's not it's not a huge because
it was only it was 16 percent here
wasn't so far 5 percent the adjustment
is relatively modest in this particular
case but after calibration the type 1
error rate is is 5 percent this is a
good example this is what it looks like
on a good day okay here's here's an
example of what it can look like
so sometimes calibration makes a huge
difference and think of it in
the confidence intervals sometimes it
widens the confidence in terms of small
but sometimes it widens the confidence
intervals considerably based on the
experience with the negative controls in
the poem and the positive controls okay
so that's that's the kind of core
methodological idea so we've just
finished a study in in the context of
treatments for hypertension drive 20
minutes or 30 minutes 20 minutes okay
and we just finished a study in terms of
hypertension and this is the what
prompted this is the recent publication
of new treatment practice guidelines for
depression by the American College of
Cardiology and various other Auguste
organizations and this document is 56
pages it has 106 recommendations about
hypertension treatment about half of
them are based on expert opinion only no
evidence okay so what we set out to do
what we have done is we took the 40 or
so major treatments for high performance
illegal treatments for hypertension
antihypertensive drugs and what we're
doing is we're going to look at all
pairwise comparisons so we're gonna do
40 choose two studies right every
head-to-head comparison of of these
drugs we're going to do it for 58
outcomes of interest these are the
outcomes that are identified in the
guidelines as the primary things that
cardiologists are interested in some of
them are good effects some of there are
bad effects
okay so 58 outcomes interest we have 76
negative controls for the hypertension
drugs outcomes that we don't believe are
associated with any of these drugs and
we ran this analysis in nine databases
around the world this particular
analysis the union of these databases
has about 250 million patients we have
about 5 million new users of
antihypertensives in in the union of
these databases the study design we
implemented is a fairly straightforward
high dimensional propensity scoring
Prensa scoring design and high
dimensional meaning that the propensity
models have about a half a million
predictors they use the entire medical
record for prediction purposes but it's
a fairly vanilla albeit scale propensity
method but we do the calibration so we
in sick we ensure afterwards with this
post-processing step that the 95 percent
intervals cover the truth ninety-five
percent at the time so we've gone from
on the left is the 40 drugs are around
the circle the I know you can even see
it there are a handful
randomised trials that provide evidence
about the comparisons so we've just
filled it in okay so here are the legend
results we did ten thousand two hundred
and seventy-eight comparisons it's a
total of 1.3 million studies and that
we've we've done there are the results
okay so that's that's all Studies on
hypertension for all outcomes if you if
you give me a little poetic license and
so here about eighty four percent eighty
five percent of these studies are not
statistically significant so fifteen
percent of them are statistically
significant that shouldn't necessarily
be five percent because some of these
really are real right the actual studies
in the actual hypertension treatments
are the actual outcomes of interest just
for comparison purposes that's what the
medical literature looks like so we did
a scrape of observational studies from
the medical literature and extracted
point estimates and standard errors let
me flick forward and backwards that's
what it looks like if there's no
publication bias no pee hacking and
correction for the factors that I
mentioned that's what the literature
looks like we have a problem and okay
let me finish with the following so
there is an issue about okay 1.3 million
studies how do you browse this how do
you understand this how do you interact
with something evidence on this kind of
scale so we have built a variety of let
me skip this name so time we've done
comparisons with randomized trials I
could talk about that offline and so we
built a whole variety of viewers and
ways the visuals this is all available
right now you can get it on your on your
device and the legend basic viewer takes
you what you allow you to drill down any
one study if I could click on the the
lower link please so we built something
that we thought was a bit of a gimmick
we call it legend med central to mimic
PubMed Central it should come up in a
second so we thought this was a gimmick
because what I'm about to show you
hopefully all going well oh there it is
okay on the screen and what about to
show you is an example of this so we're
drilling down you pick a drug and you
pick a comparator these are all ad
studies in this particular context you
pick an outcome that you're interested
in pick angioedema alright that happens
to be one I did earlier on you pick one
of those databases or you can do a
meta-analysis pick CCIE and then click
search so what you're doing is you're
drilling down on one dot in the cloud so
this is and your demon
new users in cinebulle you can click on
that please again an abstract that
describes the study and the results of
the study and you can go one step
further and if you bear with me this
takes about 20 seconds you can generate
the PDF document all going well it's
generating the PDF over there it takes a
few seconds what you're about to see is
a full-blown paper automatically
generated right it has everything you
would see in a published paper except
for the literature review that's the one
thing we haven't automated but other
than that is a complete description of
an observational study so we week there
it is so we can generate and if you
scroll down through that you'll see
kaplan-meier curves and plots showing
prayer and balance before and after it's
propensity adjustment and so on and so
forth so I sat we did this for fun but
in fact it's a serious way of actually
visualizing and interacting with this
results this massive results database
and thank you I'll stop there
you